this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
couple things for the room I want you to
take a look at Daddy
is there something different about me
aside from the fact that I defy time
okay take a look
because I'm I'm noticing it I'm going to
notice it right now what do you see
about my
just my face liver spot in your head
face what the [__] are you talking about
I'm trying to figure I don't have a
liver spot on my hand
your cool new cake I think I'm a little
less Gray
and I'll tell you why I think I'm a lot
yeah you look a little you put some dust
up there no I didn't put anything in
there I think I'm I'm on a supplement
regimen and I swear to God I think it's
gone it goes what give them the promo
code no I don't have it oh God I don't
have a I don't have a company I'm I'm
paying for expensive no here we go but I
think that I'm I think that I'm like I
called Rogan and I go dude you've been
taking supplements I've been making fun
of you forever and now that I've been
taking supplements I will never go back
because Brian I know I go no but I have
feel so good my energy goes who are you
talking to you've been anti-supplement
forever even though two of your best
friends me and Rogan swear by
supplements I didn't know you swear by
supplements me yeah things almost since
I was like in fifth grade man like what
do you take all sorts of stuff man this
isn't about me what do you take well all
I know is I think my hair's gotten
darker
and I know all you guys just looking at
me and I don't really give a [__]
somebody said it does look dark on top
see yeah is it more full let me see that
is it it's so weird though
I mean I'm not joking I think I'm kind
of Blown Away by it I don't know I'm
taking but I'm taking him fish oil or
I'm taking uh Omega-3s with um from fish
oil with CQ10
yeah whatever the [__] that is that's
supposed to be good for your hair yeah
and then I'm taking vitamin D then I'm
taking a really high and a multivitamin
I'm taking tonkat Ali which is supposed
to raise your testosterone by 10 to 20
that's not real I don't know that's not
it's a it's a it's an herb yes I take
creatine and I take magnesium at night
it's not and oh I do a green and I do a
Greens Plus thing like an athletic green
yeah in the morning I think all of it is
[__] real
oh wow you really you really changed but
you're you're like that next week it's
gonna be us no no no no no I I
been talking [__] about supplements for
a hot second and here's the here's the
real thing that tickles my [__] yeah
is we've been sponsored by audit for 10
years you piece of [__]
yeah but I was taking without it I take
the krill oil was awesome
I take these
zoomtech is amazing would you assume
that like fish oil is not as do you
consider that a supplement uh well krill
oil is and krill oil but it's an old
it's a fish it's fish oil right oh you
mean do I talk it is eating fish yeah
would you consider that supplement like
you can get that in your food like
creatine get if you eat the only reason
I believe in fish oil is is anecdotal my
my well no 100 I'm asking it works yeah
yeah that's science but but I'm saying
you but there's a difference between
eating fish and taking fish oil so my my
uncle was 90. he had he couldn't walk
very well he'd ate fish he was very very
healthy literally he's 96. he started
taking fish oil and he goes whatever
that he was always skeptical like I am
he walked uh 40 blocks he goes it's
unbelievable the difference in How I
Feel damn official like 40 blocks yes
because his joints were more you know I
don't know they they worked better no
he's doing fish oil and cocaine right
now that there's no way because fish oil
is not known to do that right I think it
is
[Music]
yeah yeah because if you have uh helps
with your joints joints helps with your
joints that's what I mean yeah so at
night and it takes a hot second to kick
in though like you'll be taking it for a
while so are you saying that my are you
saying that my house
anecdotal story is not scientific he
took one I was like I can walk off fish
oil omega-3 fashion if it has an
essential for proper develop eyes brains
yeah fish oil is great well either way I
think that I'm I've noticed a difference
over time right it takes a while it
takes a minute all supplements I guess
yeah like three months even steroids it
takes eight seconds for six months HH
Tate you're looking at six months before
you see a benefit yeah super expensive
testosterone it takes a wild man all
that takes a while yeah
when you're finally on the kick huh yes
there's also that placebo effect too
within that that's real too where he
takes up I mean I feel stronger you go
in the gym you're like man I'm taking
this stuff I feel stronger well I do
think I don't think that uh corset
mushrooms which is what shroom Tech is
it on it yeah and I do think that a
creatine does make you stronger I
actually think that's all signs though
yeah it's not like yeah that's nothing
to debunk there right we know for a fact
15 like study yeah apparently someone
studied creatine's in red meat like a
[__] like all those guys that do
the you know the carnivore diet like the
creatines through the [__] rooms
great to make your fat face now
because it monohydrate stores a ton of
water now ton of water now
now I'll tell you speaking of
supplements I got a little confession
now I was taking propitious you know
it's taking you know I don't know that
what the hell had happened
I thought you you took it years ago you
said make a wiener limp no it didn't
make my it never made my that's what you
told me that was the problem no I said
that it had no effect on my weiner I was
one of the guys who was like right so
I'm like this doesn't have any effect on
my dick I take it well well Brennan
start taking it again
and um
I forgot you know I just take it I don't
think about it it's a pill I don't know
and I was like I looked at my in my
mirror I was getting a little chubby
here Bob oh yeah that's about me Daddy
you know I'm not like that I got you're
you're
ectomorph yeah so I'm like what what's
going on here and then my boobies were
getting they felt a little bit like I
was like is that gyno hot flash what's
going on with that but that's not even
anything
I uh I was crying a lot
now you know I'm dead behind this yeah
estrogen in that so it sounds like yeah
let me get to it let me get to it I
gotta get to it because you know I'm
pretty dead behind daddy that ain't
ain't emotional no yeah you're basically
seriously Daddy was crying you're like
meatloaf and Fight Club oh oh Bubba I
was crying over bring him up chin I
would start crying because it's a tiny
thing and Danny my my wife would go are
you crying again and I was like I don't
know what's going on with me then I
tried to make a speech at tarc's wedding
and I couldn't get through it Bubba
that's a wedding though I don't care
about Tark I know that's you there but I
was crying he had big tits he he got it
on video he was like making so much fun
of me it was hilarious but I was I was a
weepy Willy you're more emotional I got
I got you know I got my boy my boys uh
looked under my hood said we're gonna
look under your hood oh you did all that
studies and they said now your
testosterone's high you got high
testosterone you don't need testosterone
at 56. sounds like some haters makes
sense right I got high testosterone yeah
I've always known that yeah we know that
but they said your your sex binding
globular God is yeah whatever it is is
it's called goblins it's tying your
testosterone up so you're not freed up
oh so you don't have your free
testosterone right and your estrogen
levels are super high I guess they're
supposed to be at something like seven
they were 37 something crazy like oh
it's because you've been reading all
that liberal [__] like you're like
voting I thought that was what it was
Bob so I stopped reading all that
liberals yeah and then that didn't
change anything
and did it hit you when you were
marching in the gay parade the other day
they said they didn't hit me in that
either wow I figured that would do it no
because I I because I have a great wig
and I have somebody I was wearing high
heels I hurt my feet okay and I thought
the pain you weren't crying it wasn't
crying okay that didn't do it maybe
maybe also being a bottom and poppers in
my nose
taking it deep yep that didn't do
anything that was in a red flag no all
right so so I'm doing all this stuff
doing all this stuff I I mentioned that
I was taking Propecia and they were like
well there it is and then I looked it up
look man you might keep your hair your
estrogen levels go through the roof I'd
rather be bald bro I was like I took
that [__] I was like this will never
happen it's like and I'm back to being
dead behind the eyes with a lot of
energy well it's like that Rick and
Morty episode when the Devil comes to
town he opens a pawn shop and he's just
giving stuff away and people are taking
it and then the devil is like what do
you want the guy's like I want all the
women so he gives them all the women and
then comes back he's like what my dick
doesn't work this is a curse so it's the
same thing with you it's like I would
rather be bald damn right high energy
than have a full main correct tits and
love handles correct why is that a side
effect that's true because when you
block tea
h t which is a certain type of
testosterone which creates the balding
yes yes
um it's also an important part of your
estrogen protein it's also yeah I'm
sorry DHT it's also a um it's also a
very uh important component of your
overall testosterone dude finasteride
and estrogen that these include enlarged
breasts in men increased body fat levels
sexual problems are you kidding me right
now no estrogen can also lead to hair
growth hey man
right I don't give up that's why male to
female transgender persons take estrogen
injections or patches wow I mean bro do
your base turn in a check bro
emotional big red flag when we're at
Starbucks you're like refer to me as
they I was like dude what is this your
hair looks dope then yep and I I know I
said remember that because you go hey
dude and I go excuse me it's all full
circle hey bro and you went bro you
hitting me with your heteronormative
heteronormative capitalist imperialistic
male patriarchal comments long sentence
yeah yeah you remember that I do
remember bro your hair is looking good
you went bro how dare you it's a they
and thank you today today I am I am
category less yes all right damn hey
forget Propecia dude well I did Bubba I
had to forget that [__] but your hair is
popping hair's popping so that's the
other thing still got tits yeah that's
the other thing take supplements your
hair pops
he's just been doing nothing my hair is
darker I'm pissed it is darker it is a
little darker it's I want to make fun of
you it's kind of a little darker I know
weird very weird so I might you don't be
surprised if I if I start looking 30
because you know I move like 30. yeah
yeah you got to take care can we take a
little break dude yes should we take a
little break okay real quick your brain
needs a break yep for sure and I'm
taking a break you're taking a break
next week I'm taking a break next week
the fine kid is going dark next week
there will be no episodes Brian is in
Jerusalem I want to Israel dude Israel
and Jordan I'm hit in the Middle East
you're fighting the good fight yeah I'm
going to do some stuff I'm going to walk
in in we can't talk about it we can't
talk about it the stuff you're doing we
can't talk about it finally kid is off
next week so stay tuned and we will be
back the following week with some more
fun podcasts oh yeah this episode of
firing the kid is brought to you by
Better Health better help you have to
take care of my brain it's so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you trust me and never take a
moment to think about you need for
yourself but when we spend all our time
giving it can leave us feeling stretched
thin and burned out look let me explain
to him you need somebody to talk need
therapy dude you can't just be a friend
it's got to be a professional I'm
telling you I've been there sometimes
you just need somebody to talk to and
you go through your thing and you're
like none of my boys want to hear this
and I feel weird talking to them but you
can get you can get paired up with a
licensed therapist in under 48 Hours
yeah if you're thinking of starting
third person give another give it find
another person they will help you but
I'm telling you sometimes talking to a
therapist that's licensed that knows
this stuff is a game changer if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with your
licensed therapist and switch whenever
you want no additional charge find more
balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com fighter today to get 10
off your first month that's better
help.com fighter
listen you know what the best nuts in
the world are I do not Damien us you
know what the most expensive nuts in the
world are Macadamia if there's one thing
about us we're nutty dude we're nutty
we've always liked not we want the best
nuts in the world the best fat profile
in the world the best nuts for satiety
the best nuts a lot of people who are
into longevity take eat macadamia nuts
because they are incredibly healthy the
best fat you can get
they but at the end of the day if you
want the best nuts and the tastiest nuts
how some Macadamia our sponsor
vertically integrated with 90 Farmers
that's how the price is so low that it's
not just for the rich rural South
African communities and their struggling
economies this helps so many people but
it's also these are unmatched in their
oh they're nice and their price point
the chocolate covered the dark chocolate
with the nut Butters how about the cold
pressed extra virgin Macadamia Oil which
you can cook my mouth is watering right
it's got a smoke point and a buttery
flavor that's better than anything else
it's no added sugar or artificial
ingredients they're the best they have
flavors like blueberry coconut white
chocolate plain chocolate my personal
faves then they never do a discount but
House of macadamias they have such a
good offer if you're going to find the
kid Army for limit time they're giving
you guys a free box of their snack bars
it's the variety all right one of each
flavor when you visit House of
academius.com
tfak plus 20 off your entire order of
these delicious this macadamia nuts with
code tfak
houseomeacademias.com tfak get you the
best nuts on the planet
yeah yeah so that's the curse like have
a full set of hair we have some tits and
saddlebags correct and your wieners who
would make that trade there are people
just shave your head dude
here's another thing and I want to see
if you do this I know you don't but this
is why I have problems I went to my
son's fifth grade graduation now I don't
know if you know this but in Santa
Monica if you were just born you're
amazing and special and every step of
the way I have a huge problem with all
this must be celebrated yes if you have
a recital everybody's there yay you can
some of it sucks like dude you're so
good it's the Woody Allen joke if you
sound like somebody's sawing a trumpet
in half it doesn't matter your parents
are videotaping it you're amazing it's
incredible okay
so uh that I I'm right with you on that
I don't believe that that's how you
should be raised actually I think too
much affirmation could be too much like
anything else I'll get in the real world
and get kicked in the nut yes you're
like oh everyone's not don't think I'm
the greatest no my son goes fifth
grade's a little different because it's
interrupt your fifth grade I can under I
think all of it's [__] fifth grade I
can understand because he's going into
middle school if we're gonna celebrate
you celebrate fifth grade there you go
in graduation high school correct and
then graduation college so you have
three celebratory I'm right with you on
that too but even fifth grade my parents
it was very sweet though because the
music that they have a musical director
that does an amazing job the kids are
all playing great so yeah it was
beautiful I like them so
um but here's why I have problems I'm
I'm just watching my kids it's all the
other parents what I do is I go like
this I just stand I'm standing and I'm
assessing every dad I'm looking at his
jawline I'm looking at his belly and I'm
like I'm in better shape than every
[__] Father Here usually that's how
it is and if it came down to it if there
was a squid games if you lock that door
and you just outrun all of them you said
Brian here goes there's a squid game
you're gonna outrun all of them right
well is that where you're going with
this you're gonna outrun all of them
right Brian no I'm not you're gonna act
tough around those dads yeah okay go
ahead you said no do your thing you said
everybody's gonna go you gotta fight for
the death you outrun them put your money
on me [__] in a race 100 no hey
no raise hey you're pretty fast you know
I don't like this stuff man you don't
this difference between me and you and
this I know you're more gay than I am
yeah because when I do those things I'm
checking out the moms right you're
checking out the dads that will always
check out the moms too but now now if I
was in a public school there are plenty
of men who are going to give me a run
for my money but there's something about
a a private small Santa Monica School
different right demo little different
demo now I've come to my school oh well
that's yeah that's that's where you got
real athletes I'm the poorest I'm the
we're by far the poorest man
an athletic pool that that's a that's a
real athletic like power I've never seen
anything like it right and everything's
anything because the dad's like oh wow I
mean just NBA dick in my face the entire
thing real life big black dick just all
right yeah monsters monsters so you're
not even you're you're I'll make you
feel bad uh no I'm not quiet you know
they talk to me but I have to like shine
their shoes and stuff yeah
it's humbling well you do you're not
walking in
let's put it that way you get a second
to be like for you in high school there
it's like you'd be
in the mo you be in the mix I'd be funny
I'd be the funny guy people like you
guys like me but oh like it'll hurt my
feelings like my son came home was like
Hey this kid and this kid this kid
they're going to Belize whatever for
summer what are we doing I'm like and
then all the dads are going they don't
I'm not even they don't invite me no
like they know like they did the first
day and I was like what no what no huh
how much is it oh absolutely not and
they're like yeah he's joking like no no
no I can't afford that you know yeah
because yeah and then I think and for my
son you know he's just like I don't why
can't we go I'm like
I don't well I don't have a hundred
thousand dollars for that for a week I
was like dude his dad owns the [__]
you know the Lakers do they figure it
out yeah
yeah now I will give this to make you
feel like [__] though I'll tell you
where I don't feel like [__] I'll tell
you where I'm fair you know where I'm
talented you know what sport or what
physical activity I'm obnoxious
homeless shelters I'm obnoxiously good
at where as in where the person I'm
learning from says if you don't do
something with this this is a problem
that's a paid person it's not a paid
person tennis nope nope dancing dance
daddy's taking some salsa and some
Merengue oh no he can dance you've
always been able to dance I know but I I
got I get the body for it kids got it
kids got it and and hey
full circle here right you're a gay man
dude and you are fighting so hard and I
appreciate it dude but it's safe we're
in a safe spot now especially you feel
safe hey it's why it's because we're
leading I think you're leading me into
it no it's pride month dude if there's a
time to come out right now right now and
get our number and you won't and you
won't knock it hey take one for the team
get our numbers up you come out as gay
yeah that episode's huge is that right
yeah dude I'll do anything for numbers
as you know come out and Now's the Time
now do I have to bang somebody on camera
no no no you never have to go that deep
okay now if you want to make real money
we start the only fans and I manage it
and and have I get the homies over right
we film what do you say homies it sounds
like you're talking about white guys
[Applause]
[Music]
is it called is it called split null
gray is that the uh is that the title of
it's called Panthers coming
Panthers coming Panthers coming I'm
talking about that Panther tail so
throwing up Panthers break the throne up
breaking breaking open medium and gray
oh dude medium and wrinkled if you guys
like
gilfs hey do you like finding the kid
You're Gonna Love rink and the black
Frank and the block you obviously you
didn't say rink in the blacks no just
black it's one guy one guy only but he
start big boy okay
it's a real takeoff it's not rink in the
blacks no no it's just the black you
know like the mountain from Game of
Thrones it's the I'm thinking of that oh
you're right somebody impossible oh it's
a it's a how's it going to fit in his
mouth
I want people to watch this art and go
how's it going to fit in his ass so
and then we all tune in so we're making
bank dude I dated a girl who um
uh her friend was a masseuse this is the
[__] strangest let me ask you what
you do in this situation I was dating
her her friend's a masseuse she was a
real blonde Vixen and she shows up I'm
sorry she's still doing it I don't know
this is all alongside now okay she shows
up at my house to massage me and she's
got a pair of
um sweats that are down kind of like
down real low yeah I can see the
beginning of her ass yep and and she's
got her thong popping out the top
nothing better right that's when I go
she's the same time Bobby she's gonna
massage me oh no no and then she's got
correct your apartment whatever she's
got a shirt a t-shirt a tank top like a
guinea tea yeah a wife beater instead of
a set of hitters in the front no bra
tied in the knot oh dude
read the room
so read the room so I that obviously
obviously you're all about me keep going
the thing is that all she would talk
about is how she has her boyfriends are
only in the NBA and only as big and it's
black as it gets he's an honor keep
going and she was telling me about how
big uh she called him Big Daddy he was a
famous basketball player and how his
dick went impossible it went over his
hips it would go all the way over his
hip of course it does and she said I had
to deal with that yeah sure what are we
gonna do and I'm thinking to myself look
I do all right daddy does all right but
I'm not that guy no so and I told him I
was like why are you dressed like this
and are you trying to bang me but you
keep telling me about this guy and
you're massaging me was there oil
involved yes oh but I didn't do anything
because I didn't want to I didn't I
don't want to I don't want to initiate
contact because also my girl we were
casually dating but I mean if you're
gonna send this girl over what are you
are you setting me up
well do I think about it every day yes
now here's the thing am I going to
thinking about later today yeah yeah and
jacket hard dude yes oh what a time to
be alive I can't shoot or shoot dude
that's why you're not in the NBA shooter
shoot you did nothing now you pipe down
what Mophie figure it out let me know if
you want to go to double date come on
you and Big Daddy and me and Amber were
the [__] that'd be cool God you're cocky
oh no be cool man I was dead full circle
dude come on hey man what straight man
can have the lambor redeem myself though
okay
there was another time where a woman
would come over and massage me and I was
sincere I was sore daddy runs it hard
yeah his back was tight need my
backwards Daddy's back tight balls full
and my back my calves what what gets
tight on you because my Cavs ache my my
hamstrings get real tight yeah and
nothing's better than a nice foot and
hand massage really my wrist I don't
like that oh no no I like I like my
traps oh I'll tell them the back straps
rub down I don't give a [__] about the
back I'll tell them feet hands wrist
really and then my head how about the
ass I'm gonna dick what how about the
ass what'd you say
you don't like having your hips isn't it
weird how it's frowned upon to get your
wiener massage but your feet it's just
skin correct just one sweats a little
more well one when I say sweat I'm
talking that thickness one sweats the
other barfs well that one sweats a thick
nectar right
but why is it why is it frown upon your
banana how is the skin on my nuts I
sound like you're in court a lot right
now getting busted for [__] human
trafficking your wife I'm sure she'd
understand
babe how is this tell me how
my dick is different yeah
that's correct well it'll go well in
your house just run it by it okay let me
before you before you set the house on
fire it's scientific here different than
or the cells in my feet not the same
skin cells I'm a Nut well my buddy who
we have a friend who was in a political
relationship he found it as his lady was
with a guy who was a friend of his and
he did that he goes in his mind he goes
well how is it different than a back
massage oh I remember that we had dinner
he's on a plane he's like okay let's go
well if that's case I want a back
massage right
there might be a difference between a
foot rub and a foot and a [__] down oh a
real proper a proper [__] down this girl
just uh this girl just got up on my
wheat she'd massage me probably five
times and I was at her place is he good
or she's so hot today she was
outstanding and she was more of a
granola-y crunchy hippie girl yeah and
she got right up on my she got right up
on my piece and just off the bat right
this is no this this was after
five six things but I've never made a
pass at her but would she would she like
give the proper massage and then yeah
never I got a great story about it
because I that was never the case she
started talking about how she would
release guys because she doesn't
consider it sex it considers it part of
the and that Spirit that's the and she
was mentality you need in the business
and that's what I was probably very
accommodating of her philosophy yes why
wouldn't she be like this yep and I
think at least my traps as she was
talking about that and how that would
turn her on I can still did nothing no
no I got oh I got
rock hard and she said turn over and I
said if I turn over it's going to be a
little embarrassing she goes maybe to
you but not to me oh game I went and you
still did you go and she got up on the
table gifted and sat down on things oh
wow yeah yeah and we had sex oh wow and
then every time I would have a massage
she would do that
and uh what a glorious time well the
best time well no it's the best time sir
and you know Wednesday two o'clock the
massage come on massaging the dick suck
well because by the way massage costs
you if you're generous with tip 120
bucks whatever and and I was getting and
I was getting all the other stuff that's
always nice because you're on tip are
like 200 she's like I'm not a prostitute
it's like well no but right you earned
it but a great gal you earned it right
such a cool girl and so and I never gave
that vibe off so I never flirted with
her she was a professional masseuse sure
took your job serious yes she had a
great dog and just like a real Earth
Mother an Earth Mother yeah Earth mother
that loves [__] well I know heard the
mother who is she's out helping with the
[__] God she's all about she's that
female she's that powerful female energy
that can absorb male energy like the
ocean yep and her kryptonite's [__] yes
well you know is that because I keep
going yes but your [__] is your [__] is
like whatever you think she can absorb
all of you with her mouth she can all of
whatever it is she can absorb your meat
your energy whatever it is she is an
ocean she's an ocean yeah man she's a
healing no you know if she's still
continues well
my buddy says to me I need a masseuse
pick him up but I I swear to you I'm on
my life I I I'm very very private I
protect I would protect her privacy I
would never tell anybody this ever no
you're not gonna text your buddy I got
something for you and she's never never
I would never do that she's the best 100
because this was a personal thing with
us that we were like she I knew she
liked me I think as I thought about it
she liked me and we used to have great
cut talks this is how good she was you
think you're the only one so now I like
the stripper in the club dude I'm
telling you she loves me man right yeah
yeah how much was it buddy oh does
cinnamon love you we started off as this
as friends we started off it was it was
it was literally a true professional
relationship
hold so my buddy goes
do you have a uh do you have a masseuse
I say yes and then he said what's she
like and then I said to him I I because
he's a good friend I said she's great
and uh have you and he said something
like have you did you guys used to date
her I never dated her but actually and I
all I told him was that I've hooked up
with her while we massaged oh I told him
the loose variation of this story but
only because it was it was surprising to
me it was something about I wasn't
saying else but he took it
he took it to believe
that she was about that that there was a
happy ending she swatted his dick away
about a year later
I find out that his friends are all her
clients
and that that's been the case oh she
made you bake she was making bank damn
dude I thought I was gonna go the other
way I was like he tried and she's like
no right because that's why I would
never tell I would never tell somebody
about that now all the homies getting
some it ain't fun if the homies can't
have nothing but I was like but I
thought I was special I know
professional professional that's a real
skill set it's a that's an earth mother
and anybody who has a judgment on it is
I'll get yours girl get yours until that
one time this is years ago when I was
living the Palisades there and there was
that app I don't know if it's still
going on
you can order people to come to the
house massage they bring everything so
you don't have to go to Massage Envy
yeah order one they don't show it's a
female male I always pick female males
will get real tights and gay right so
the female came in the house this
chocolate
this chocolate angel showed up
even my girl's like what what the [__]
is where yeah it's like I gotta be in
the room oh oh yeah oh yeah she's like
you can do it in the living room like
yep
I was like what are we doing I never
would do that again no just this
chocolate angel yeah with a full mouth a
positive attitude some short shorts I
was like what are we doing here man yeah
that's that's uh yeah what do you I got
kids well that's trouble oh
can relax through that you don't want
that hot my buddy
and he used to deal with that all the
time with the guys would be like can you
go a little lower and he'd be like nope
gay guys he was like in his 20s trying
to work his way through college he was
like well they stopped the guy who
doesn't want to say he wants to happen
he's like I'm real sore like here like
the back like
my glutes are real tight [__] okay oh my
cock's all tensed up man my cock's just
that's a knot yeah
do my dicks all about wound up hold on
you got a balloon knot we gotta loosen
that yeah
yep and then you got this this is real
tight yeah super tight how do we get rid
of this you know I'm looking for a
release
hey we're 10 years old huh
well I guess this is also that culture
dude that's just that culture well
there's a there's an app where where
that has rub mats or rub maps is that
what it is I educate Eric and Chris on
this they didn't think it was a thing
yeah
of course it's the thing of course it's
all over man you gotta pay that premium
membership though to get the details
they tell you ask for AMG ask for Cali
really yeah all right
I learned about that because I had this
opener when I first started stand up in
every city we went to she was like I'll
see you later man here's the easier we
could pay me ahead of time like what are
you doing and then I saw he was on his
head he's like look there's one a mile
and halfway and every city you go to and
he paid for the premium membership real
great paid for the membership was like
oh look this Melissa whatever gives the
best and here we go you gotta give her
four out of ten like four there are
strip clubs I'm not gonna say that I've
been but there are strip clubs where
where girls are I believe that [__]
there are [__] men and female who put
themselves in positions so they can [__]
all day long oh yeah like they're
they're there was a place in La it's
called Hollywood no there's a place in
L.A where where those girls would
literally in the back room do whatever
and they were doing that with everybody
and it's like you know you're doing that
to strangers something's going on with
you for them it's like shaking hands
yeah like some porn stars I guess no for
shaking hands right that makes sense
they were doing it because I've seen you
suck 12 [__] on [__] right and
it's like you're into that yeah yeah
they don't it's not frowned upon
open-minded open if more if more of the
world's open-minded be so much further
along dude open-minded be open-minded
yeah go to glory hole mix it up my buddy
my buddy is standing on the on the
street corner and a beautiful red
Porsche pulls up and two insanely hot
girls step out and my buddy's a flirt
and he goes what's going on here and
what are you guys doing causing all this
problem is this recently and they yeah
and they started talking and the girls
go the girl goes you are so cool and he
goes thank you he's older and uh and
they said you know you make me you make
us feel good about ourselves and he said
well that's my job and he said you know
it's funny that's our job too and if you
ever want to work something out let us
know and he goes tell me more and turns
out they were both professionals
and uh right on the street there and he
uh now has two gals that he calls
whenever he needs he's a single man
that's how he spends his money kids are
all grown I don't know how much it is
but you know he's got to be cheap
because the only fans in social media
[__] it because they get money off
there for just like you know rubbing
their tits together with oil they they
don't have to work as hard anymore man
well I you know I I was very naive but
um I guess a lot of Instagram accounts
are basically a call girl I mean they're
they're basically like hey my private
correct is this so correct you want to
work something out pretty awesome right
yeah and and I I do know that a lot of
those girls when the NBA is in town
their DMS kind of well the All-Star game
is basically becomes You Porn yeah
All-Star game they all flock there they
do right yeah yeah like ducks to the
South yes there's a whole thing why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you well if
you're if you're young hungry young dumb
full come get down to the all-star game
it's amazing yeah slice them dragons
ladies slicing Dragon slice them NBA
dragons here we go
get your work cut out so you you're
hydrated do you think that guys in the
NBA professional athletes get laid a lot
I don't know dude I don't know that's
always been the debate
always been the debate my own wife
but this we were hanging out with this
two gals in my body and she had just
broken up with this guy in who was the
NBA and I said how tall was he and she
was like 6 10. and I go that's too tall
and my wife my wife goes too tall do you
know anything about females you think
that's too tall yeah they wanna they
wanna protect her and I was like
oh okay I guess not to talk to you
either yeah I guess I'm sorry I'm not 11
inches taller in a lot of different ways
I like literally looked down I look down
like I was like I'm still not over your
thin legs yeah I was like yeah okay yeah
sometimes that'll hurt you well just
being around our boy um
um I mean you know he's a monster I went
to work out after that you know did you
yeah and I was like I don't know what
I'm doing here yeah he's yeah I mean
you're talking about a freak freak he
was good right surprisingly good he's
great yeah smart people forget yep
meerman was a monster
don't you think that that
um most great and I might be wrong maybe
aren't most grades in football really
smart
because they have to be or no no I
wouldn't say the all of them are smart
I don't say any names but how about how
about socially intelligent though
no
really we're not dumb asses but
it's it's yeah doesn't the Playbook
require a lot of understanding and
learning or no am I if you're a
quarterback that's why all of them are
most most of those are analysts like
Tony Romo Troy Aikman all those guys
Boomer syson Phil Sims
Tom Brady has a deal like the
quarterbacks are yeah they know the game
I'm sure Drew Brees was not dumb Drew
Brees uh analyst too he's on uh they
just know they know they know everything
you're the smartest on the field yeah so
that's why that's why they always make
the best I'm always amazed at Chrisman
yeah Chris Collinsworth is another one
who knows he's a receiver but monster
great great player but Hall of Famer I
think yeah but but he because
Collinsworth knows she sees stuff that I
would never see just like well you see
that left guard was pulling on this side
that's all he played be but then if he
comes in as the stand-up world but his
ability to see the whole field like that
is I I don't I I just can't see it Joe
clatt's a beast you know he's a
quarterback so smart guys yeah he's a oh
so he was a really good player really
good huh 64 years old I know I went to
Florida
yeah he's great wow
you're like that how tall is 36
touchdowns played seven years six five
oh geez damn I know he's six five that's
a big boy oh yeah he's a freak
especially back then playing 81 6'5
white boy Hollow damn follow you feel me
had some good hands huh yeah Chris
Collinsworth was damn good All-American
hmm
I don't know if he's a Hall of Famer but
he's [__] good
Sean Marin I doubt he won't be in the
Hall of Fame he didn't play long enough
I don't think years
on and off he was I don't know how the
NFL deals with PDS because he tested hot
yeah oh so you think that that has a I
would assume
I I don't know I don't know how the NFL
does it
75 games
and he was a he was a pro baller but I
don't know
he's he's actually a big linebacker even
by today's standards 268 pounds six four
two sixty that's a big that's a big
linebacker and like right enough enough
for the outside linebacker man really
yeah why because they have to be able to
guard they have to be able to just the
the freaks so he was two-time first team
All-Pro second Team all pro three-time
pro ball sack leader oh my God his
rookie defense Rookie of the Year man
you would think that I mean it's God
Beast yeah you'd think that would be
close to NFL right Pro uh Hall of Fame
defense play of the year of two-time
All-Pro
what does all pro mean like so at that
position you're the best guy in the
world
there's only one All-Pro quarterback one
All-Pro one All-Pro linebacker outside
linebacker one All-Pro cornerback you're
the you're the best of them what does
first team mean first team so it's first
team second team so the first team
that's the best of the best so Tom
Brady's first team is the best
quarterback Patrick from home first team
All Pro it's the second team second team
was like Joe burrow no it's not special
teams for [__] sake what do you mean
second so there's the first team which
is
team would be the second team if you're
first or second you're [__] monster
yeah
out of all the NFL you're the best guy
in that position
that year
that's the first time I learned what it
means yeah USA first team all this and
that I never knew what about pro ball so
yeah so there's all pro which is there's
no team no they're not playing just all
pro like to be all NBA oh my you look at
the guys that don't make that it's nuts
yeah it's nuts so all pro and NFL it's
just they don't play like in the pro
ball it's just those are it's like first
team All-American they don't there's no
game All-American Game in college so
those are the if your first team All Pro
in the NFL as quarterback you're the
best quarterback in the [__] world
right pro ball there's a number of guys
can be pro ball a number of guys so all
all pro is much much higher regarded
than just pro ball pro ball there's
could be [__] there's a AFC uh AFC NFC
and they might have three pro ball
quarterbacks
flying to play in the Pro Bowl oh yeah
but they change it they don't play games
anymore they because guys don't really
give a [__] yeah so now they do like
these weird like
tag and [__] yeah like these weird like
golfing it's a disaster it's not even
Hawaii anymore because guys were sick of
going to Hawaii yeah just want to be
done with it yeah but if you make all
all pro and your contract incentives or
nuts like when John Moran this problem
with John Morant when he got busted with
the guns and all that stuff people like
oh how you know he he signed whatever he
has the max deal so he's fine money-wise
no he lost you know probably 100 million
dollars because because he should be an
All-Pro basketball player because he
didn't because he did all that stuff
they're not gonna they're not gonna vote
for him for all pro so it took his
All-Pro status away so the incentives in
your contract the incentive in your
contract All Pro you're talking about
they probably give you a couple million
bucks just be all pro just from your
team not to mention all the other
accolades you get the sponsorship so it
gets you to a different tier when you're
all pro
but you look at All Pro list and the
guys that don't make it [__] you're like
what it's nuts it's the best of the best
I'm a very typical Spirit of the NBA I
remember in 19 you know or 2000 uh
whatever there's a an executive who was
responsible for financing movies knew
everything about the insides of
Hollywood and he went through the
difference between what a movie star is
and what an actor is and and meaning
like he went through it's a movie
Finance like back in the day yes well
any day but this is back in the day he
goes do you know who gets a movie
financed versus who is starring in
movies so they consider a movie star to
be someone like Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt
and back then we were like well Morgan
Freeman and and you know they were like
nobody's going to see a movie for him
like what the [__] are you talking about
he's not a movie star actor who stars in
movies what like you know it was there
was this different it broke my heart
that was like you know Robert Duvall
they're like nobody's going to see a
movie with Robert Duvall well yes they
are I wouldn't I know but the money says
no and they were telling me what what
they were worth versus what other people
worth and I was just like it was it was
like that's the business is it nuts nuts
even that Arnold Schwarzenegger
documentary have any of you guys seen it
it's so good it's a five-part series I'm
in the middle of it I would say don't
finish it because that this it ends sad
depend how you view it it ends sad
because well and this is yeah agree we
talked about this like it's and there's
no spoilers everyone knows Arnold's
story but when you hear him talk about
it it's one of the best documentaries
I've ever seen wow you realize he's I
mean once in a lifetime Talent like the
growing up in Austria you know his dad
was a Nazi you know his dad was Nazi
straight up Nazi General yeah his dad
was a Nazi very brutal to him alcoholic
they lost the war he took the anger out
on the kids his brother he was like his
brother was different he was I would
change I wouldn't change anything
because I was built for that he put a
chip on my shoulder to get the [__]
of Austria and become what what I became
but my brother he was more gift than me
built put on muscle better bigger faster
stronger he'd beat me in every
competition we were kids but he was very
sensitive so he took all that to heart I
did it it made me stronger his brother
ended up dying yeah in a car crash but
like his mother was very sensitive got
into the alcohol drugs and stuff I think
yeah DUI or something like that but
you're saying that that's the difference
sure he goes I wouldn't change anything
because it made me who I am made me
dream the biggest I could dream and so
it goes through all crazy like him in
Austria and getting into bodybuilding
because he saw that movie uh Hercules
you want to be just like that guy so he
started going to a gym so he got in with
the guys right and then from there then
he you know he comes a comes to America
wins Mr Olympia meets Joe Weider then
gets to Hollywood but it's interesting
because some of his movies bombed he was
saying he goes there was a time in the
90s the highest paid actor 40 million
dollars a movie the highest paid actor
of all time and he's walking in he goes
I could walk in the Universal Warner
Brothers you name it I could walk any
students off me 40 million dollars to a
movie then he bombed three times in a
row and he didn't hear a peep that's
right and then James Cameron was like
movie jail yeah and he goes then James
Cameron called him he's like yo I got an
idea for True Lies I have a movie called
True Lies that was before Terminator
yeah oh oh no True Lies is way after
terminated so I'm saying but Terminator
was James Cameron that was correct yeah
yeah so yeah well no yeah and that's why
he was the highest paid so okay True
Lies Terminator Terminator one right
Terminator two Total Recall that's all
early late 80s early 90s right then he
hits he uh Last Action Hero bombs and he
said he was so sad the the director
called him James Cameron said he called
him how you doing he didn't direct like
last section here where he calls me
because I just want to be alone he
usually took it to heart he didn't
realize the movie bits doesn't work like
that he took it to heart they bombed the
three more and he goes I used to be able
to walk in any movie studio in the world
they'd offered me a major 40 million
money says he goes and start dried up
James Cameron goes I have this idea for
a movie called True Lies gives them the
idea I remember that movie I saw in the
theater me too Jamie Lee Curtis so hot
in that and they wrote the part for
Jamie Lee Curtis and so Arnold goes all
right let's do it but we gotta make it
big he's like yep big explosions that
movie's a [__] Masterpiece below them
up and then he's back yeah then he's
back don't tell me anymore because I I
want to I want to get well you know the
story again there's no spoilers here but
I want to see it I know but then he then
he goes uh to be Governor now remember
his uh wife is a Kennedy and she's
completely against him running it for
into politics but what's weird is they
have video of him when he's a kid he's
like 16 17 talking about he wants to get
into politics like you what are you
doing he's like I know it's weird people
think I'm this Meathead but I love
politics I want to make a difference so
when he wants to run his wife is totally
opposed to it because she's Kenny she
knows what what it entails yeah she's
like hell no so then the day he's gonna
announce he's going on Jay Leno and Jay
Leno assumed he was you know I don't
want to know what they're going to talk
about I want to be surprised at the
natural reaction but we all are killing
me right now because I want to see this
stuff but I'm saying he but I'm saying
Jay Leno is just assumed that you're
giving me all the turning points that I
want to see well he becomes his Governor
Brian I know but I want to see these can
you not give me every the details yeah
I'm watching the documentary yeah yeah I
know this stuff I know but I want to see
it yeah the bottom likes we gotta do a
podcast and talk about stuff the bottom
line is he becomes Governor spoiler uh
Arnold schwarzen became Governor
I know I know I'm not going to give any
of that stuff out I know a story I know
relax we have the podcast new bike
you're going through I'm not I'm
dropping that detail Brian no I'm not
but he becomes Governor yeah which we
all [__] know if you don't run
yourself in the wall so it becomes
Governor right and when he's Governor he
didn't realize what it entails and the
effect it had on his family and then
obviously he talks about the marital
affair they had with the nanny but you
realize like that one mistake you're
talking about the guy that's done it all
the biggest baddest Governor biggest
movie star in the world Mr Olympia has
the World by the balls and makes this
enormous mistake and has a baby with a
nanny dude get away with anything bro I
mean and you know we've talked about
this isn't spoiler but he's just now
he's by himself he's in this huge
mansion
by himself
like that's how his movie ends you don't
get away with that it's I remember when
his book did really poorly because it
came out at the same time and it was
like you know that that book
came out and it's just called on it and
people are like no no thanks because
there is a limit it's like you get see
the problem with when your life works
out to that degree and everything you do
you crush you start to think that the
laws of the universe don't apply to you
you start to think you can get away with
that you're different start to think
well you just start to think you're one
of God's chosen people you just do I
mean and and then you get your Nanny
pregnant you're like I'll get away with
this too I'll figure it out you got away
with it for a long time until that kid
got
older became the governor so you know
whatever well you know I I always go
back to what Jordan Peterson said which
I've always believed you he said in my
35 years of practicing psychology I've
never seen anyone ever get away with
anything even once if you like if you
follow it all the way what happens is
it's like oh you're having this crisis
we can trace it all the way back to that
and that's an interesting idea yeah I
think I think for Arnold too yeah it's
weird how the public like they get so
mad when like their Heroes like whatever
cheats on their why or something like
that and they want to not support them
anymore
it's weird
well there's a lot you know there's a
lot that goes into that have you seen
have you seen the Tour de France
documentary the new one yeah no I I've
never been into bike racing I mean I I
like bikes but I have to say watching it
is it is such a strange the Europeans go
crazy over it it's huge map huge it's a
three-week race and like have you ever
looked at what what it entails dude I I
didn't really look at it until now so so
during the Tour de France to interrupted
during the Tour de France Lance
Armstrong does a podcast and breaks it
all down it's riveting it's crazy it's
biking biking and you when Lance
Armstrong talks about the details he'll
talk about what the guy has to go
through how far he has to go what he
needs to do to become you know the top
guy how you eat because you got to keep
your weight off you got to be skinny
you're talking about six hours of
climbing Hills every day for three weeks
and they what I didn't realize is not
like kills here Bob huh not Hills not
like them no we're talking about we're
talking about the
[Music]
and how about this I didn't realize this
though I didn't know that they were
falling at 45 miles an hour all the time
oh yeah assume crash nuts crashing into
each other [__] the losing skin and then
getting back on their bike and having to
finish getting that at night the whole
thing is recovery oh so it's all about
what and that's why apds are so
prevalent
you know what they do they sleep on the
ground they try to sleep on the ground
because the electrons in the ground
actually
um charge your body back up so
interesting you know what they do they
sleep in RVs and get EPO Brian well that
you know what they do they shoot
testosterone in their dick oh they do
all that too but they they will sleep on
the ground because they found that
recovery yeah when your body's on the
ground that's fun for the documentary
you know what they do I don't know they
take Armstrong was talking sure yeah of
course it was you know what he does what
he used to when he won all the races and
everyone's continues to do this yeah
it's called blood doping I know they do
extra red blood and white blood yes and
dripping into their bodies overnight
yeah and their blood come look up you
know what they do their blood gets so
thick they can't sleep through the night
they have to wake up and continue to
move otherwise the blood will slow down
I get a heart attack yeah because their
blood's so thick like a milkshake that's
what they do don't give me this [__] no
no listen
hold on
say that let's just do the first one
let's see what they say all right this
will be it
uh stage Wisconsin sleep in hotels
I'm following a number of people it's
fun for the doctor right and you're the
guy that falls right he wasn't in the
doctor it was just I heard yeah Lance
talking about it
last probably slipped on the ground once
right huh this price up on the ground
once uh
motorhomes yep RVs hotels sleeping on
the ground
downside of sleeping Hood twin beds okay
I literally typed in ground as in the
search for this article yeah I think
yeah which one of your [__] friends
told you that I don't know maybe that's
I'm sure I never said that what's that
Lance Armstrong you know what's more
interesting is Reid Lance Armstrong's
book yeah I have that's the real [__]
the blood doping is not dude so I didn't
read it I only read one book did you
write another book
I think he might have it's all about the
bike Iraq you know what it might not be
uh uh you read the entire book on
Joseph's bike yeah no
um no not his life about it yeah yeah
cancer and all that yeah
yeah there's a the Lance arm Lance
Armstrong documentary great it's not
about the bike that's going all right
secret race now those are [__] like
feel good stories I like the dirty [__]
about waking up middle of night because
their blood's so thick it's from blood
weird sport man
you're a team and and you know you have
your what they call your your um
domestics in French which means your
servants they're the ones that get you
food water they're the ones that keep it
keep you drafted that'd be your job
right so you why it'll be your job right
I'm a sprinter yeah hey give me my water
no right no dude hey if let's if this is
Tour de France and we're the where you
got yellow jerseys on it says U.S postal
on our back you know what you're doing
Baba you're getting my [__] water in
my EP do you know what you're doing my
EPO no you're doing I'm never getting on
a bike you're just too big you don't
have the body types for that no too big
you know they're they're like they're
135 145 we gotta be light dude yeah I
mean you know some things aren't so hey
guy what's going on it's Brendan no some
you know what I am I'm the guy driving
the [__] policia car in front of them
unfortunately you are yeah you might be
the guy who gets the bikes off real
quick and picks them up when they're and
pick them up when they're injured yeah I
bring their power bars or whatever yeah
no no there's just some things our
bodies are some things aren't for me I'm
not made to fit in uh McLaren I'm not
made to [__] ride a bike you know
they're professionals their bodies
though are just they're not great
looking bodies they're
[__] thighs dude there's a picture
when he's on Tour de France when he's
going up the mountains bro was he a
sprinter was he the guy who would like
take that he did it all that's why he
was different he did it all their legs
are stupid bro it is is that a maple
leaf what's up Daddy
world
look at that down there and they're
because their legs fill up with they get
so so much blood flow
another calves are stupid oh that's
right after a crash yeah they just get
all bunched up no biker legs are the
best that's why when Summer's popping
because my thighs get crunchy daddy look
at those cabbie calves their legs are
not to be yeah nuts
yeah there's some things I just you know
it's just on the cards for me right
being on the U.S cycling team not having
let's get rid of that narcos vein there
dude
that looks cool
do you assume that they're I would
imagine that's probably from some EPO or
whatever they're doing no dude no no
don't disregate them so EPL is not going
to give you muscle EPO literally only
puts oxygen in the body yeah they were
taking it or they were taking some kind
of a crazy cocktail yeah but remember
they can't put on too much muscle
because they'd be light yes they eat so
you know what's same with like I could
never be an F1 driver way too big so
like my boy Danny Ricardo and like Lewis
Lewis Hamilton yeah they're tiny dude
are they yeah because you gotta imagine
like the car they have to stay I think
it's like 134 or something like that
what because it's just like fighting if
they get too heavy they're gonna be slow
so those hamsters really small they're
all tiny because you know the car the
car can only be so light they have
regulations
um but the so for the driver that had
two pounds to take two pounds off that
car is a nightmare the drivers [__]
themselves they get a diet and [__] man
that's how that's how horseback horse
racing is too
yeah the jockeys they're Ty now
that's the actual car
damn I put how much do the drivers weigh
I did because that makes all the
difference huh there you go and they're
they're literally uh
80 kilograms
minimum weight and formula and Driver
well that's that's that's uh
190 almost but 170 but I don't think so
I think you're right there's no I'm
telling you I'm telling you Dave Ricardo
told me they got to be tiny let me see
what 80 kilograms 160 171. I'll look for
a maximum wage for F1 driver hold on
type maximum weight do uh oh there you
go look how much you have one driver's
weight well oh at least so it includes
their seat though it's 80 kilograms
including their CP so the heaviest you
can be is 176 pounds that's the heaviest
you can be there's no one 176. yeah
because because it's a such a
disadvantage yeah
but that is that 80 kilograms is
including the seat in the car oh Jesus
yes oh Jesus yes
oh you gotta go
oh that's a minimum though but that's
the minimum minimum wage and their seats
and their seat 176. so the lightest
driver is 119. whereas Williams driver
albon is 163.
oh my God so either usually around like
that you know between one a lot lighter
that's lighter than me I'm 173. yeah we
too big wow
wow wow I think the tallest is like six
foot six one yeah
isn't it weird yep makes sense though
yeah it makes sense it's just like uh
and by the way Formula One driving is
crazy right it's crazy I think there's
only 22 in the world at that level now
there's backup stuff like that but 22
but it's so expensive oh it's the
richest sport in the world by far not
even close that's a whole team too I
watch that it's all European yeah the
the it's a who is Hamilton's the best
right
yeah I mean no this Max kid I think his
name's Max is it been winning but yeah
Max verstappen yeah but so I guess all
the Articles say like it you have to
have a minimum so just you know you can
be as heavy as you want but the minimum
you have to be a certain weight to be
fair to the competition which is but so
that means that one dude they said wait
one 16 116 pounds so that means his seat
would have to be heavier because you
have to get to one eight yeah so they're
gonna be like all right we gotta add
some weight to the seats oh I see so
total totally so so totally when you've
got it you've got to be okay
other than so you can't just do you can
be like get someone who's 100 pounds
yeah exactly have such an it yeah like
90 years away because every car has to
weigh the exact same it's all about the
engine engineering yeah and then the the
skill of the driver so you don't you
don't want anybody going over 80
kilograms you want everybody to be right
there yeah so now you got to be and the
car has to be a certain weight too your
car can't be heavier lighter like
everything has to be the same
it's all about the engine yeah that that
whole Tour de France is crazy eight
people on a team and it's ruthless it's
like guess what dude you're 35 Thanks
for the Memories we'll see you later
boy what Lance Armstrong did for cycling
the way they treat him it's insane to me
well I think he hey name another
cyclists
anybody in the room
and well in Europe you could but the
people that followed hey hey we're
America bro right I don't think that
matters it's a European but Lance
Armstrong the point is in America but
I'm saying that overall Lance Armstrong
no one's more famous people hated him
because of how he threatened people's
wives for sure um he he was I'm not
saying all that I'm not saying I'm
saying the notoriety that he brought to
them in the money his foundation made
for them uh insane as as always people
are complicated and there's good and bad
in people but and I've always said that
too but he um
the people I know that are pretty
charitable who follow bike racing I
don't know enough about it like I
remember when this head of the Spanish
team said
publicly he said I respect him as a
cyclist I do not respect them as a
person at all and if you read uh it's
not about the bike he was a dick and if
you read other things people were like
and I and I actually know a woman who
helped me with my buy a house once she
was on the national team and her husband
was too and she was like they strive
with Lance and she had nothing good to
say about him so he earned a lot of his
reputation I'm just saying what he did
in the notoriety sure it's insane to me
sure and it was like just wipe them out
of the record books that's insane to me
and you gotta go down to 15th place to
find a guy who didn't cheat I get he was
an [__] everybody was everybody
everyone it's what they did he's the
face of it he was just good everybody
else was all good he was the best at it
here's the thing he's also the best yeah
not only at doping but also riding the
[__] bike correct and people think no
it's just because he did all the drugs
why he's so good no no no everyone did
it and he was still the outline yes by
far yes the best cyclist it's insane to
me there's no doubt
he was crazy he'll post a picture I
don't know if he does it every year but
pretty frequently when the Tour de
France starts it's him lay on his couch
like this and all his yellow jerseys are
you serious yeah can I see that
that's really interesting
you know aubry's really close with them
really yeah Aubrey's really close to
them
I mean I would never like he's paid his
price I'm not going to be a
wow maybe I made the flipping off yeah I
think you made that up but he'll post
that pretty frequently though during
Tour de France
there's multiple ones there's different
ones well that's not him that one that
one's sad that one's like a college kid
let me see ya that's them hating though
just go the original one I mean that's
the first one yeah that's that's the
famous One
five
wow he was saying when all that stuff
came out he went to a bar in uh in
Austin
and they bought him a beer [__] you and
then he bought them all their their
entire when he left yeah his kids his
kids get bullied and [__] it's not
necessary it's like go [__] yourself
guys lots of sports what do you do to
you yeah yeah what do you do to you I
know also also I'd go cool you hate me
name another bike rider oh you're not in
it you don't follow it you just follow
the gossip news you don't know me yeah
you just know the guy and that's I
usually give people the benefit of Doubt
all those people like was Lance was the
worst he was an [__] what place you
finished you you and I are both 15s okay
that makes sense oh you hate the guys
crushing it I get it no yeah I mean you
and I are kind of in the same boat there
I think uh overall I always respect
somebody who's got greatness like Barry
Bonds like that guy did they cheat or
whatever in a league that everybody was
cheating and yes they did did they
handle it poorly yes did he exhibit uh
poor character in many cases yes blah
blah blah 100 do you want to punish them
the rest of his life
is that what you want to do yeah what
makes you happy you want to go dead
broke on the street yeah because a lot
of people want that I've never liked I
remember there was Matt liner
UM quarterback for USC Heisman Trophy
winner and uh bad Pro I don't know much
about him but that program great
announcer now yeah and and I'm a guy who
follows Sports said
um we I saw him at the airport we were
getting on the same plane and my I said
I think that's Matt liner I don't know I
don't know and he said yeah yeah yeah
yeah with the Cardinals he goes he's
done he's done after this year he's done
yeah he got exposed something like that
he did this with his hand
and it really bothered me
[__] bothered me I was like hey don't
take a dude like that who's that great
who did everything in college okay it
didn't work out so much and for us but
he's a pro no he's a pro quarter oh dude
he was a starter in the NFL thank you so
a little respect you who never did
anything don't go ah like shut the [__]
up you don't know what that was about
that you don't know what it takes to be
that guy that guy's outstanding that
[__] right there he's not he's
an outstanding human being no matter
what happens you try being that
outstanding as a human being but that's
why like that's why the Sheep he'll take
your girl also he's six foot six yeah
also shut the [__] up Let the Sheep talk
because you know they're not gonna say
it to the they did it to Tebow they did
it then I can say to the wolf's face
they're gonna talk behind because they
would never take those risks so all they
do is Judge they don't know what it took
they couldn't walk in the shoes of Matt
line you know good Matt Leonard just in
high school he can graduate up here you
know [__] good that guy was talking
about real Sabbath oh my God a starter
you said he was starter in the NFL yes
you go ahead and try that CeCe get a
starting quarterback please I'd please
what how'd you do started in high school
but you know that's a success story
either way correct let's say you didn't
play a single down for that draft in the
first round and what for a reason just
didn't work out for him you know it's a
crazy success story
you oh you sure you don't go like this
ah he's done ah you don't take a human
being like that who's that outstanding
and go like that I can't stand it well I
can't [__] I follow I follow Ryan Leaf
on Twitter I don't know where he is oh
man so Ryan leave this is one of my not
my biggest regrets but this shows you
how I was bad at making picks even as a
child Ryan Leaf came out and uh that
draft class it was either him or Peyton
Manning and I was a big Ryan Lee fan
because all his games were on TV because
in the pack back then at the time played
for Washington State so all the
conversation was who should be number
one Ryan Leaf or Peyton Manning and Ryan
Leaf is bigger than Peyton Manning Ryan
Leaf is a monster he was so good in
college huge Ryan Leaf was very arrogant
very [__] key so when the Colts we're
going to take the first round pick they
flew Ryan Leaf and they flew Peyton
Manning Peyton Manning came in and was
like studying film was asking questions
like breaking down tape like Jesus
Christ is a maniac Ryan Leaf was like I
think he was talking about how he didn't
want to be in Indy and how the the
weather sucked it was like real negative
so they went with Peyton Manning by the
right choice best quarterback of all
time regarded yeah Ryan Leaf was a
disaster like it had a really bad
addiction to Pills and alcohol fizzled
out of the NFL I would have taken him
you know I was I was also eight so [__]
off but even then I had bad pictures but
Ryan Leaf right so that does that
regarded as one of the biggest busts in
the NFL
he went to prison dude went to prison
his stories and saying you gotta watch
the 30 for 30 on it'll break your heart
so he goes to look at that prison Bubba
so now he goes through all that so now
he takes this horrible thing that
happened to him
and he gives back he tell he helps
football players in the NFL like these
are the traps you gotta be careful of
don't do the same mistakes I do he goes
speaks negative to a positive he goes
yes he's a motivational speaker now as
well he goes to to the prisons and tries
to motivates them so that would be a
success story a hundred percent he's a
success granted as far as the NFL
happens as far as NFL goes number one
pick bus yeah for sure still success yes
a human being he had a correction but
he's a much better person now but you'll
see on on Twitter and he'll go at some
of these people these people are still
so mean to him and he was like he was
literally like some guy saw he goes
Bubba I was the number I was the number
two pick in the 1996 draft you [__]
idiot he was like I was also I also
finished second in Heisman voting I also
said every passing record in pac-10
history
in what facet do you think I was a
failure I've had I've been I've watched
I've been in rooms where people were
criticizing how Anthony Joshua boxes
because he got [__] up by uh
anyways like it's like dude can you oh I
won't entertain him well if you made it
to the UFC it's a huge accomplishment
it's a huge you know how hard it is to
get in the UFC but come on then you know
how hard it is why because of all the
different leagues and how many people
are trying to come on well that but then
just you tell you a step further so and
it's taking me a long time for even for
me to get this level so I always felt
like a failure at C when I was in
college because I wasn't Tim Tebow in
college I felt like a failure when I got
to the NFL because I wasn't uh Tony Romo
in the NFL
I felt like a failure when I got to UFC
because I was in Kane Velasquez
sure then that's my that's how I am
that's that the constantly that was my
perspective but you got to realize when
you step back it's like hold on if I was
eight years old and you go hey dude you
know you didn't play division one
college football not just like go and be
on the team you're gonna play it like
holy [__] that's insane yeah cool then
after that you know you're gonna get a
shot with the Buffalo Bills like oh my
God this is nuts are you serious yeah
dude and then after that you know not
only are you gonna fight in the FC
you'll be ranking the top 10 in the
world I'd go get the [__] out of here
this is gonna be the best life ever you
don't have that perspective when you're
young it's taking so much work for me to
step back and go it's because of my kids
step back and go oh damn that's pretty
cool man yeah this is a cool story I
still don't do that at all very rare do
I have who is the best black belt
anybody had ever seen continues but but
you know what I'm saying it's all
perspective because even even again the
top ten you know the chances of you
getting to the UFC winning fights you'll
like this you like if you break down
anymore you know the chance of you
fighting on a main card you know the
chance of you headlining a UFC
pay-per-view you know the chance of you
being uh the main event of a UFC it is
not good if you go off odds it's gonna
hurt your feet my wife put it in
perspective for me I was complaining
about you know uh not having a big black
dick just I was just complaining about
uh
I wasn't complaining but I was a little
bit bummed out about uh not selling
theaters or you know some some of my
friends are selling lots of tickets and
I was like you know but but I'd sold out
that night and you can go down that
route I mean she goes she said to me she
goes hey Brian
somebody took a picture with you tonight
and when they walked away they went like
that they pumped their fist
there's a guy but yeah yeah but but it's
like be a little she goes be thankful
for that and that's a big deal and I
never do that and I never that's almost
impossible that's almost impossible to
do it's like if you're a Navy SEAL and
you're in the middle of war and like
dude we're some bad asses they're like
what no this is what we do do well the
bullets flying who gives a [__] that's
what we that's we're used to this so it
is a extreme example with the Navy Seals
but it's just a I need to be more
grateful and I need I need to be more
thankful for where I'm at I mean and I
try to practice you should be in
theaters though like you talking in
common you're you're you're a monster
you're the one that taught me stand up
but I'm super grateful for that out of
everyone you know no one gives you the
crate you deserve we've been over this
yeah like you're the reason I have I I
can afford private school for my kids
for doing stand-up you know that's all
that's all Brian count you're the one
that pushed me
you should be a theater act you know and
I having it towards people for it that
you're not I'll be I'll figure it out
I'll figure it out I'm not there yet you
should be there and it bothers me you're
not
I appreciate it
let's talk about black dicks
thank you for that you know yeah but
it's all perspective because it's
perspective and it's about practice
when you you know after you have a older
son now but even with the baby like when
you do more cool things like you like to
kill yeah I know Brian was on Mad TV
which is insane that's insane dude I
know Brian was on sex in the city I know
Brian was in The Hangover I know Brian
was in uh old school I I know when day
one when I met Brian The Hangover I know
all this we but we see each other we're
best friends it's whatever but then when
you hear someone else talk about it like
yeah oh yeah he was like holy [__] that
was a big deal you know it's like oh
yeah yeah I know man no [__] it's a big
[__] deal you get you get it from
your kid like with my son when their
their friends talk about their dads and
my you know my son a list off stuff and
he'll come back and like Dad you did
this I'm like yeah mom told me to do
this I'm like yeah is it coming my God
tell me about it not stupid and they're
like oh no it's not stupid it's not
stupid it blows his [__] mind dude
yeah and you're like oh my yeah I guess
that is cool when you start talking like
oh God that damn that is cool yeah man
yeah [__] yeah and that goes back to the
fact that I'm in better shape than every
dad at that [__] graduation at that
at that school right that's that's for
the gifted right mentally right so that
means even the dads have a touch-up well
right even the dad's little towns right
Special Needs school that's fine
you feel good about yourself but you
need those moments I need those moments
dude let's take a break for a second
let's take a little break to talk about
a nootropic not just any nootropic Alpha
Brain they've sold over a million dollar
million bottles a million dollars way
more than that million bottles fan well
you got Alpha Brain you got Alpha Brain
instant you got Alpha blame Blacklist
that's what I use you take that that
stuff is the best you'll get today look
at me Alpha Brain Focus shot Alpha Brain
pre-workout why what what about it try
it it works also they got total gut
health for you wow the krill oil we were
talking about this you're taking
supplements around the world creatine
protein powders yes they got Warrior
bars they got streaming
kettlebells oh steel Club Macy's home
fitness programs they got it all but
they also got the best nootropic on the
planet we're talking about Alpha Brain I
take Alpha Brain Black try the shot try
the instant try the regular Alpha Brain
get your money back if you don't love it
go to audit.com
f-a-t-k Temp stuff everything all black
label get hard Focus shot pre-workout
instant Alpha Brain temps on off that's
audit.com
f-a-t-k get home we've been at this a
long time man long time well it's like
my son he's really into baseball he has
a he has a coach he works with and he
has tryouts it was just hilarious for
seven year olds but it's so competitive
they have tryouts in uh end of July
and uh we went to the I've been taking
him to the the batting cages and we're
throwing all the time five times a week
and then yesterday uh he hasn't been
able to do the fast pitch the the jugs
machine he he just it's [__] fast
dude for a seven-year-old it's so fast
and yesterday he's doing it he's hitting
it I'm like oh [__] he's getting better
thank God because that baseball's not my
thing but I know the mechanics part of
it and just the work ethic if you want
to be an outlier I'll get you there yeah
so driving is like Dad I'm tired I'm
like good that's what we need dude and
then uh there's the reason one of the
reasons I'm not
torn so much in the summer as I told
myself I'm gonna dedicate myself to him
for baseball he's he plays basketball
and he's good Jujitsu wrestling he's an
outlier football he's good
um soccer he's good and he's the big
baby baseball he gravitates towards and
so I told him I said but you're like me
as a kid I played everything but you're
kind of one foot in you have fun your
friends are doing it I said your graph
training towards baseball and I said if
if you want this dude I'm telling you
got a dad who knows I do I'm gonna I can
get you pretty far and then the rest can
be on you but all you have to do is
commit and I go all your buddies this is
what's gonna happen that's what happened
with me in the summer your buddies are
going like you told me they're going to
Fiji and they're going to Paris they're
watching YouTube and playing video games
you're gonna be working it's not fun I'm
telling you right now it's not fun but
boy is it worth it I said if that's what
you want I'll show you the blueprint but
I'm telling you man it's worth dude it's
[__] work buddy it's not gonna be
cool it's not me cool your friends are
gonna want to do this and this you're
not going to be able to do that your
friends are going to want to eat this
you're not going to be eating that I'm
telling you dude that's what that
Ronaldo says and I I told him I said I'm
telling you dude we can go down this
path it's a [__] I said but you
know what's cool if it was for everyone
everyone would do it it's not if you
want to be an outlier this is what it's
going to take and it's not going to be
the coolest thing showing those is he
showing real talent yes and I said it's
not gonna be the cool trendy thing to do
but trust me the juice is worth the
[__] squeeze dude sacrifice now and
live like a king later all your friends
are gonna be doing all this [__] We're
not gonna be doing this is how old seven
that's pretty wild did he understand and
I and I and I told him and you know I
try to make kids really serious and I
was honest with him I said I'm
committing myself this summer to you man
it's you and me buddy you're waking up
with me I'm running with him in the
mornings at seven run with the hills
with him in the mornings we're doing all
this [__] I told him I said it's gonna
be work man I'm down to do it and then
he's like uh yeah that's what I want
because the batting cages he was kind of
not doing great and he goes again I was
like I like that I didn't say anything
because I I'm not like again you know
I'm like whatever you want to draw let's
go no I'm like let's go dude I don't
give a [__] but he's like again I'm like
all right so he hit he had won the first
one was like a foul I'm like that's not
great so I put a token in that time he
hits five again and it's late we're done
it's 6 30 already the sun's coming down
we did an hour and a half before
Sprint's base running throwing hitting
he was again all right put a coin in I
run out of coins I go to him all the
coins just oh that can get more like
yeah I can get more go back how long you
want to do this he's like tell me you
gotta here I got five coins here this
means you would have hit 10 times dude
it's like 20 balls you know that's a lot
of [__] it's 200 balls you're hitting
here dude again again again we get in
the car and again I'm not a trophy Dad
I'm like bubba this is a lot too
if you ever don't want to do this you
want to go play video games with your
friends do that buddy be a kid yeah but
if this is what you want
it's this everything he loves it loves
it
is he isn't that I made him laugh I go
if you're scared go to church
he goes why are you scared to go to
church drink a warm glass of milk that's
right so if you scared go to church he's
laughing so hard you scared and when you
pass my truck I pull in I'll pull in if
you you wanna play games and stuff go to
church that's the greatest he's laughing
so hard I love that [__] I I love it I
and now you can watch uh his TV in his
room he watches TV for 45 minutes before
bed he likes to relax online and then I
I we have a camera that so I can see
right and so I told him I go when I was
yours I was obsessed with football only
thing that mattered was Football
Saturday night was Saturday Night Live
outside that it's football dude I was
obsessed not because my dad told me
that's what I want to do with my life I
was obsessed with it it's all if you
want I was an expert in football it's
like that's what it takes so I tell him
that and I'm like but have uh we're
gonna watch boss baby or something like
that he's like yeah I'll figure out I'm
like all right have fun dude and I I get
on the camera watch boom watching
baseball
he loves Bryce Harper how well they have
this similar hair is he is he uh gonna
be a monster is he a big boy he's a big
boy he is
so he's got he's got Daddy's jeans
although your wife and her brother's no
slouch no her I mean her brother played
college baseball it's athletic kid yeah
when he was throwing catchers are the I
don't know if you remember we were
throwing we were throwing those little
round rubber balls at each other oh when
we're at uh and he started throwing the
ball and I was like dude that ball was
like uh it looked like a UFOs oh geez
you don't realize when baseball players
throw oh holy [__] no you know his lip
he makes a living teaching baseball dude
he coaches a team they just won the
championship they all got Rings sent a
picture of all the Rings he does
privates from Pasadena to [__] Malibu
like big boys like he's a baseball
expert yeah my son has that our boy
Kevin bass got that baseball gym in uh
in Arizona and I was throwing I was
throwing I was trying to throw pitches I
think I I got up to
68 miles an hour or something like that
I don't know whatever I don't even know
what's good I mean obviously the pros
are throwing a hundo and we're never
gonna do that I don't know what's going
to start throwing the ball and I was
like oh lordy lordy lordy
bro like now I'm getting more into
baseball I'll watch videos because I'll
watch some to help my son out with like
timing and his Bat speeding and foot
placement all that so I don't seem like
I'm bullshing them you'll see these
little Puerto Rican kids who are at six
bro Cuban or Puerto Rican there's both
Dominican Dominican Dominican it's
Dominican Dominican the Dominican kids
who are like six yes
and there's no way there's no private
training they're just playing with each
other baseball since for six years it's
in their blood it's it's best coaches
everything else there's a whole book
about the coaches there there's a
picture on
I it might be the Padres I forget he's
19 years old I think he's the youngest
he's like 19 or 20 but he came from the
Dominican yeah and you just look at him
like holy and he throws yeah it's like
Pedro Martinez my size but just throwing
you know oh there it is Yuri Perez yep
I hate
probably not a small kid either
so 20 year old became the youngest uh
player of the season to make an open day
roster
yeah he's born in 2002. bring him up let
me see what he let me 2002 isn't that
crazy yeah
Beast
it's crazy these young kids man yeah
that's some 19.
all right that's Julio yurias that's
where the Dodgers
yeah
yeah did I mention I'm a good dancer
this picture too you're a good dancer
dude yeah the only thing too is like we
talk about
um they get the freak
we talk about like you know CT and like
even me and Sean Mary were talking about
how most cases people aren't going to
get it but as a dad my son doesn't have
to deal with any head trauma and can
play baseball very nice be very nice
it's weird to be around the other
parents though and they'll be like yeah
you know hope sticks within you know but
hopefully he's a Dodge or ammo
he's six yeah I don't talk like that
myself no I tell him to throw you in
doing you want to be a someone you want
to be an outlier in high school
because there's so much that goes on it
let's just focus on being the best we
can right now and go from there play D1
college that's a big deal even that's a
bit even that's a that's a huge gap of
course because because you can get
drafted out of high school dude I saw
it's like I just want you to be the best
but but pop one taking it into a D1
program as a football player like for
example or a basketball player hardest
I've ever worked hardest hardest thing
I've ever tried when you see who what
those D1 players were like in high
school it's like holy [__] like you see
all these amazing guys in high school
and they don't make it to a D1 program
oh I'm usually Colorado like there was
guys who were Walk-Ons that never played
and they were first team All-State the
the high school quarterback stud didn't
sniff they're lucky they got a jersey
you get there it's just a different
animal man now take that
and then those guys don't have a chance
of playing and then look at the NFL it's
to get to the NFL is so mind-blowing I
know it is it's but that's what I wish
people understood but even with the UFC
it's like
it's so nuts how about just making it to
the Olympics as a wrestler like Daniel
Cormier you know how hard that is the
hardest I mean hardest gig in the world
like twice by the way twice and being
successful at it yeah go ahead
go ahead
and then Jon Jones takes you down uh
what do you got yeah you think about
John that's what I'm saying it's like
people don't realize like when you see
is he wasn't he's not the goat though
when you see Izzy Jon Jones Daniel
Cormier tell me who has ever come close
to taking down Daniel told me no no but
he's I'm gonna double it he has that
sound
and broke his will like DC you ever see
him look at the clock no he was like DC
is the most impressive heavyweight or
fighter in many ways just with what like
you could say his best combat sports
athlete as far as wrestling credentials
I have no problem with that Strikeforce
credentials UFC credentials I got no
problem heavyweight champion UFC light
heavyweight champion Olympian Strike
Force world champion never lost that he
won't say sahudo I think DC is more
impressive because the the uh the margin
of errors and that size dude when he
when he went into the you got to realize
when he won the strike force Grand Prix
fighting Barnett Antonio Silva the what
yeah I remember those fights and
remember he was five nine five ten like
literally and five eight five nine yeah
and and was you know uh hadn't been
missing any meals walks into was a 205
who got down to 205 walks into
heavyweight picking Josh Barnett up
taking
um uh our boy our boy uh she carries all
the guns and knives um Frank doing
whatever he wanted just unbelievable man
just too much for all of them do you
know how good you have to be to beat
Josh Barnett back no good Josh Barnett
the war Mastery son of a [__] the war
Master is his name listen with Josh
forget shooting forget gun Josh violence
for Josh of my concerns is his resting
point if I'm with Joshua I hope he
shoots me correct that's how dangerous
he is a straight up Warrior do you have
a gun why because he tapped here on
Gracie
tapped him yeah he has even bigger
accolades I mean you're talking I'm just
talking about grappling oh stupid yeah
all right what do you got Jen
all right you get more tattoos Junior
getting blasters trying to look like a
giant Travis Barker what Where'd I get
you get more tattoos getting blasted
Daddy I want to get more tattoos you
want more on the legs
are you training I do lift remember I
went back to like one time a week hold
on no I was doing like three four times
a week that I sort of got lost and did
one time a week now I'm back to let's
get let's get that consistency yeah yeah
for sure it makes me feel a lot better
are you in the Yakuza not the Yakuza I'm
Korean too so well Koreans can be in it
yeah
Yakuza are ethnically Korean which
people aren't which is crazy yeah oh
Brian you know I got into lately you
know I always got on these where I was
into the Unabomber for a little bit he'd
commit suicide dude I thought he was
dead already I had no idea he was still
alive he actually came out I'm just yeah
he hung himself yeah he's tried before
though but they say he has a big
following though like that Manifesto on
like you know
yeah hung himself wow brilliant mind
you're like mine just couldn't take it
anymore
I'm gonna pee I gotta P I want to hear
it all right
old school old school podcast
I'm eating these boys might be back boys
might begin together doing a little show
I'm at a theater speaking of theaters
you and I might be doing a little stand
I do have a little firing kid merch that
I am so impulsive firing kid merch on my
story today like is this real merch I
saw this in a store it's a fire kid Army
shirt I was like that's real like this
isn't a knockoff I'm like no we did that
six years ago nice what store is this
all right well the Abbot Kinney fight
club stuff I think you guys need to
bring it back soon
always talk about I've been saying it
really day one yeah yep I wish we could
I'd love I'd love different colored
t-shirts yeah I think you do the
original the gray stone we do it of
course can you set it up let me check
with the guy yeah I'll do it I've been
saying that I've been busy blah blah all
right I'll cry my car on the way here
sometimes yeah what I'll cry in my car
hard on the way here dealing with the
[__] we got to deal with you kidding me
dude
excuse me excuse me you want to add that
to my table right now always Sunshine
under above the clouds all right let's
go if people only knew anywho oh I know
I wish I could talk about it
um so Tucker Carlson he did a show on
Twitter after leaving Fox 122 million
views like I think even more than that
oh is it up that was like that's like a
170 million views for just after two
episodes but he received a season's
assist litter from Fox because I guess
they're contracted with him until the
end of 2020. yeah but on Fox here's the
caveat with this it doesn't say anything
about social media yeah
listen Tucker is a very smart man
despise what you think of his political
views I don't care very smart man you
don't think he checked in with his
lawyers hey go over this fox contract do
you see any verbiage where it says
Twitter they go there's nothing on that
yeah checkmate
170 million views yep and then his one
yesterday on Trump's uh uh indictment
yeah dude if you are a trump fan it will
fire you up you're like oh this is why
you'd vote for this man it fires you up
Mike and Trump gets Chuck on his side
and if you don't like Trump you're in
trouble
well I would say if you are if you are
in favor of
forget Trump because I've never been a
trump supporter but if you are in favor
of liberal politics and you believe that
progressives are good for a city I would
direct your attention to San Francisco
and the Westfield Mall Nordstrom's has
closed shop the Westfield mall has given
the entire Mall back to its creditors
can you tell people what so Westfield
all the malls you see so in in Studio
City uh if you go to
um all the way to Sacramento if you go
to the Park Meadows Mall in Denver any
of those big outdoor they have the main
mall in the auto Mars all owned by
Westfield yeah they're massive they're
out of Australia I think they're like
the lifeblood of they're the best balls
yeah it's so bad in San Francisco
they laughed they the mall left you guys
drove the mall out of business Whole
Foods left as well yeah because you're
because the city council they're not
even Democrats they're Communists and
and admitted socialist and Communists
you guys are the biggest scumbags to
serve what you get San Francisco if
you're gonna reboot yourself this would
be my question if you're going to vote
left this will be my only question
should give me one example give me one
example in every major city that they
voted blue that's doing well
give me like if you're gonna convince me
to vote I'll do you want better no I'm
telling you say give me one take out
take out the three larger cities uh that
are all run by progressives and we'll go
from Chicago Chicago 189 and 193
countries in terms of safety it's those
cities that cause us to be a country
you're talking about New York L.A
St Louis I'm talking about Detroit I'm
talking about there's a whole list the
list is it no that listen I've seen this
the list is La Chicago New York if you
take those three out we're 135th
actually worldwide yes but if you take
out Philly St Louis and one more say
Detroit if you take those sales we are
189 out of 193 in safety so you know
those are just the stats and You're
Gonna Keep voting that one no I don't
like any I think they're all scumbags I
don't have a a dog in this no but if you
if you wanna if you want to cause and
call uh drug addicts on the street
taking a [__] unhoused neighbors and
campers like Portland does like San
Francisco does like like Seattle does
um but go ahead you do that and see how
that works out like La was for a while
until they came to their senses see how
that works out
um when you don't want to enforce the
law and you think Criminal Justice
Reform means taking repeat offenders and
just putting them back on the street no
matter what they do if that's what your
idea
crime got bigger yeah it gets bigger so
um they're so stupid they're so dumb
well that's why it's a it's a one horse
race well who's going to beat a
republican I also have a huge problem
with progressives idea of what gender is
but that's also me because they think
that kids should be well that's on the
left the kids know why would you know
what gender they are okay and and so
they should have irreparable operations
and drugs that make them sterile when
they're seven eight nine and ten if you
actually talk to them they they actually
will say a kid knows what they are well
you tell me so funny you tell me I'm
name a parent support I have to have a
parent with me if I only get a tattoo
under 18 but I can chop my wiener off
and my parents might go to jail well
they're there that's right well there
there are there are bills being
introduced on the floor of California
let's say I know they'd say hey um if
you get in the way of a child's a gender
affirmation yeah from the house you you
are engaged people got to be careful
with that stuff people are criminals
they're scroll bags yeah they don't want
to make the world a better place don't
call it gender affirm and care for kids
it's called child abuse and child
mutilation yeah the problem with like if
you see those bills like holy [__]
they're going to take the parents away
from the kid if they don't allow them to
transition when they're six whatever you
got to be careful because we read that
the chance that I get past are not good
yes yeah be very careful there are a lot
of pills that are introduced that are
insane let me ask you this question for
you I don't know why I asked Eric and
Chris this I've really [__] up because
I don't know [__] about politics let's
let's say we live in a world and this
could definitely happen Trump's
indictment people got to be aware if he
gets in this what they're fighting right
now Trump's team is fighting if he gets
uh the he goes through the judicial
system if it's in Florida he's away
scot-free if it's in DC or New York he's
[__]
let's say it is in DC New York that's
what he's fine right now let's say it's
in DC where he's gonna be really [__]
let's say he gets 30 years he won't
serve 30 but he's going to go to prison
if that's the case
if Donald Trump goes to prison
what happens to America
now remember over 70 million people vote
for him and do you think people which I
don't think I think he definitely played
a part in the January 6 riots
that was nothing compared if you lock up
a former sitting president so let's go
now hold on B yeah before you answer
that you know history you're the best
person asked this you know history
can you go through the list of dictators
that imprisoned they're constituents
that that imprisoned other people that
were running against them if you want to
go through the list of former world
leaders that imprisoned former
presidents it will scare the [__] out of
you if you go through that list yeah I'd
say the difference here is that there
are a lot of Republicans in power who
want to admit it but they would love to
see Donald Trump oh 100 knocked out of
the race
I'm sorry not by any chance to win Trump
I think DeSantis can win if he goes if I
become president I will pardon Trump
because then you get the Trump
supporters that'd be his biggest Ally
move he kind of said that he's already
hinted in that he needs to be very good
but he's the problem is DeSantis is not
going to be Trump in the primaries no
chance and so so but you're assuming
Trump right look at what's going on with
Trump you've got the indictment in New
York that's Alvin Bragg now that
indictment is this that indictment is to
say you paid hush money to a porn star
that's not illegal but he is making the
case that it was a violation of campaign
Finance reform okay that's a weak case a
lot of people say it's a weekend okay
that then you've got big ones the doctor
you've got you've got the you've got
Jack Smith in uh DC in in DC who is
saying no I think it's Miami I'm sorry
it's in it's this is the Florida case
because it happened in Mar-A-Lago the
president was asked um there's another
indictment coming in Georgia and Georgia
is that he violated election fraud and
no he violated a a statute where he said
find me those votes which was can be I
think deemed election interference in
one way the way it's worded yeah so
there's there's a there's going to be an
indictment of some kind there
the mistake Trump made was that
documents well he had he had the
documents they said give him back he
said no they said give him back he said
no that's why Merritt Garland said go
get them so they they go to marlago they
get the documents they get them back for
whatever reason because Trump is so
either stupid arrogant or crazy or
egotistical he said uh yeah you got them
all he was holding on to about 100 of
them his law he told his lawyers he gave
them all back his lawyers find out that
he didn't
now his two of his lawyers reside
they're like this is you know I signed
an affidavit I gotta resign this is I'm
gonna get in trouble here I'm gonna get
in trouble
because remember Mike Pence and Joe
Biden had classified documents when they
were a lot when they were alerted that
they had those in possession right back
so what what the justice department you
go through the list of former presidents
do that and the reason that justice
department does that is because when you
want your Presidential Library writing
your Memoirs you have access to all
those documents yes and the doj goes hey
by the way you got to give them back and
then give them right back they give you
a grace period yeah with Trump he didn't
do that not only that he held on to him
not only that there's a recording of him
saying I know I've got classified
documents the problem is this it's it's
two things one there is a clear
violation of the law and there are
people right now not only people that
work for his campaign but in general who
are in jail for this violation correct
okay the problem that that he made
is that that he [__] uh
well well he had an opportunity and he
didn't yes and he got caught now it's up
to the D.A to say you you broke the law
it didn't do any damage it didn't do any
damage nothing and and so is it did you
technically break law yes but in the
spirit of Justice am I going to let you
off they're not going to let him off
there are too many people who want him
to be invited because when he's in that
it's going to cause a lot of problems
for him and I I think their whole agenda
is to make it so he can't run because
they're terrified if he's gonna run
because he's coming back to in pain yes
retribution he's going to come back with
a vengeance so the word about that which
isn't good for America no that's not
good it's not good for they just don't
want him to run so I think all this even
he doesn't do prison time they don't
care if he goes to prison they just want
to make sure he can't run yes that's the
whole thing but he's also got another
issue which is that he called e Gene
Carroll a whack job in the town hall and
she's sued him again so he's got that
lawsuit that was whatever though but
he's going to spend it he's going to
spend other two million dollars
money-wise for sure he's got to deal
with a lawsuit he's got to deal with
three indictments the indictments is the
big one because the other stuff he can
still be present the indictment if he
did end up being guilty you can't run
he's screwed yeah those other ones he
can navigate but I would say Trump did
this to himself when it comes dude give
the documents back dummy don't say that
you didn't you know and then and there's
a document missing about the there's a
there that I can't remember the name of
it but isn't it scary that a sitting
president can go after
a former president it's not so much
yeah the department just can do that
it's a little scary
it's always been the case the sitting
president can also pardon Trump and
there might be a precedent for that
because if if he doesn't win dangerous
when our presidents are can be open to
this kind of politically motivated uh
it's all politician motivated we know
that yeah that's what Skies that's scary
because the same weapons you're using on
Republicans are going to be used against
you and here's the problem it doesn't
help anybody it doesn't move America
forward don't forget something really
important one when Trump was handling
those classified documents he wasn't
present he was a citizen but here's the
other thing you have remember to be all
this stuff have you seen the polls
lately
because they know it's politically
motivated and they're just trying to get
them to not run but but the other thing
too is with Trump is
for whatever reason if he's caught up in
this indictment he can't debate
they're still going to vote for him yeah
because the first Democrats
Democrats and Biden won't debate is
outrageous to me you don't want to
debate you don't want to have dialogue
you don't want to defend your positions
really so you just want to be you just
you're just not interested in debate wow
because they'll be getting annihilated
but but here's the biggest thing that
people don't understand the motivation
behind people getting behind Trump is
the double standard Hillary Clinton
dude that was a real violation that that
that that that did compromise probably
American uh intelligence 100 dude what
happened to her though beam well well
I'll tell you what happened James Comey
decided not to press charges the head of
the FBI because it was politically
motivated he was doing a book tour now
yep said nah and I think that's a
turning point in American Justice and
American politics Comey said Comey said
he went on CNN it was the problem people
got to realize we can vote for Trump
it's gonna be scary he's going to use
the judicial system the doj to come
after you know his his enemies I'm sure
I'm first on that list it's like like
hold on is that not what you did to him
so wait you're worried that he's gonna
do exactly what you're doing right now
is that not alarming to every American
citizen it's insane to me and he will
and it'll be a retribution and and I
think Trump trump is ultimately
destructive I think because he's such an
egomaniac I I'm a desanta supporter I am
not a trump supporter but I'm a descent
but uh unfortunately I don't think uh
Ron DeSantis will beat him I think he
can
maybe if this stuff is making them
bigger though with Trump's fanatic fan
base like when they keep doing the stuff
they're like oh they're trying to
discipline them and go after them you
use an illegal it's all they don't
believe anything they could have video
of trump lighting these classified
documents on fire and they still be like
no he's fine RFK might be the side
effect because RFK is taking votes
they're worried about them from Biden
and from yeah see RFK has right wing and
left wing uh yes suppose against Ukraine
and he's against Ukraine war yep now
remember whoever's against War it's
never worked out if you go through the
history of politics in America anytime
someone's anti-war they will because we
make so much money off War the ukrit pay
attention to the Ukraine right now it's
very important because anyone who's
anti-ukraine War they the doj they want
to [__] you Trump's anti-war Bobby
Kennedy's anti-war they're gonna make
sure they don't get that platform they
want war dude that's an interesting
that's that's uh that's anyone there's a
lot of money JFK anti-war a lot of money
shot in the face yeah a lot of money and
more all the money yeah all right go
chin we're deep [__] today dude you come
you come to the fire and kid on a
Wednesday you better pack a lunch and
come to this you don't know what we
might hit you with you know what I'm
saying
yeah I got really into it you know it's
like I'm saying oh I got into the the uh
you know I went down my Unabomber you
know again in the serial killers I go
I'm reading a book and Osama Bin Laden
right now right and then the next
chapter I just started reading a book on
a song yeah wow interesting story it's
Osama Bin Laden she called Osama yeah
it's great who wrote it do you know I
don't know
yeah I literally just look it up on
Amazon and ordered like the top ranked
one order a few but the newest one I got
Saddam Hussein interesting story you
know when they captured him 10 years
later but you know when they captured
them oh that osama's ten years later but
when they catch him he was like six
months later there our special forces
were looking for him they found a bunker
Delta a mile from his house and he was
in the bottom of this like wood bunker
and they get them and then they're the
the intelligence is interviewing them
and they go all right where's the
weapons of mass destruction and he word
for word goes we've it we've never had
that that bush made that up because he
to protect his daddy none of that's real
the first thing he said
and then so the intelligence one told
Bush that he said yeah he's full of [__]
then Talent officer did an interview a
few years ago and he's like I gotta be
honest man there was no weapons of mass
destruction we know this for a fact we
know they didn't find it and but they
said when they had nuclear inspectors we
had we had them there they do they said
when they got uh Saddam the first thing
he said he's like there's no weapon and
they were like what when they
interviewed somebody kept talking he was
yeah he's really honest and like this is
weird we're expecting like this demonic
like weapon of mass destruction it was
not the case and they say he was very
smart very prideful
interesting when you know when they when
they were cheering him
and he was getting the Commonwealth
sheep well he called them he said you're
monkeys you're not men they were putting
the news about his neck because you're
not men you're monkeys in a tree they
said the only time they saw him cry when
they're interrogating them is when they
brought up his kids his daughters he's
like I was a good dad and he said I love
them they loved me and I'll put English
I'll miss them dearly and started crying
he was such a butcher you know his
Heroes Joseph Stalin it's never good no
not a good guy in any way Joseph Stalin
uh imprisoned his they used to do what
they do what they would do to political
prisoners to really break you is they
would uh they'd blindfold you for two
weeks in a Cell they just have you blind
yeah but the first time your eyes hit
light is so painful well it's not just
that I'm glad you said that because
they'll let your eyes get adjusted to
the light because they're going to get
adjusted light but you're going to hear
something weird and sell in a behind a
glass wall
in full view you'll you'll watch the
your wife or your daughter being
violated by a man who was paid by the
government to do this he would rape your
the women in your family yeah whose job
is that and well he was a guy who was on
the payroll yeah I found that he was he
was a guy who was responsible for
defiling the honor of political female
political prisoners or the wives of
political prisoners so you would come
too and you'd see that so dude how about
Saddam so he had a nice guy with Hussein
and his other son who were actually
crazy
they're insane horrible people but uh so
Saddam was married to their mom yeah and
then he's at this thing and this hot
blonde Saudi sits down with her husband
and Saddam goes I like that they tell
the husband sit down the wife sits next
to Saddam he starts whispering in her
ear they go the the husband like Saddam
likes her he's like that's my wife like
we know he likes her he's like no that's
my wife like you'll be compensated yeah
Saddam ended up marrying her what yeah
well he's again oh and just left his
wife and told his told his buddies she
found out she goes wait hold on oh he
got married yeah yeah so don't get
married
a what it's over yeah yeah move out yeah
he didn't do himself his buddies told me
yes oh Saddam you didn't hear him
a [__] wedding yeah yes and just so
you know uh used to also do this he had
his henchmen the people close to him and
then once every two three years whatever
it was they would all disappear kills
him because he's like you guys are uh
you know I can't have you that close so
I'm gonna now they would just all it'd
be a Purge oh his head his head general
which was his sister's brother his best
friend he grew up with since he was six
yeah his head General they started
losing the war when they tried to uh uh
take over Kuwait no yeah yeah right yeah
they were losing Kuwait they were trying
to and they got their ass whooped he
blamed on that guy he's known since he
was seven you know what happened to him
oh next day helicopter exploded randomly
how crazy he didn't tell anyone he goes
it's tragic
what that was your best friend yeah yeah
he was a real peach what's interesting
is in the interrogators go when they
caught him not a small dude and in shape
oh he's a big man is that what they said
he was six two and they're like in in
shape oh yeah oh yeah a big strong guy
he was a gangster yeah he was a gangster
so interesting huh oh he's an
interesting dude very interesting guy
smart guy very interesting yeah all
right what do you got you all right
here's a quick one good listen write it
down keep going so oh real quick said I
was so crazy he thought when uh except
like with Osama Bin Laden he's
Afghanistan right so in uh in Saddam
where he was at he was like oh this this
can be good we're gonna be able to
partner up with us they're gonna help us
he didn't think there was going to be a
war he's like they're gonna help us
because we don't [__] with Afghanistan
we built his we helped we built his
armies yeah we built his army he was our
Ally against Iran yeah we supported we
gave his troops satellite coordinates of
the Iranian correct National Guard you
know we told them where he thought he
thought he was glad Osama Bin Laden was
our enemy because he was like it's our
enemy too we're to partner up and take
these [__] out that's right no sir no
no
no they can say I'm a terrorist I don't
[__] with these guys let's get these
guys America's like no no I don't know
if you remember when he used chemical
weapons on the Kurds and his own people
yeah horrible horrible good guy 100 000
children dead uh think about that 100
000 children yeah
he was like whatever a butcher a true
butcher all right give me more alrighty
sure yeah all right here we go Georgie
uh fans sent this in uh this is a small
business owner that somebody stole from
so they followed them back to their
house
and documented it oh nice job what she
steal do we know yeah one second guys
okay so this Rabbit Cafe
and stole from my store
I'll stop in my store okay and we're
gonna follow her to her house because
it's gonna pay for it there right
yes okay
so enjoy the ride and well like know
where she lives
let's play a game called look in the
thief's purse well let's see what she
has stop oh you also took a skirt did
you see that yeah
you raggedy [__]
look at me like I'm crazy and you stole
from me the irony right
down steal from small businesses
so it might feel bad for the lady no I I
do because I'd be the worst copy me too
I'm like all right what happened like I
know I'm the wrong guy because I would
never enforce in this case we're
liberals I'm a liberal it's a system
it's the system that did it to us you
know what you know what white privilege
you know what in a lot of ways you and I
are a couple Libs when it comes to that
I just I just am not I'm not good at
that stuff I could be a dictator but
don't show me don't bring me the people
because they could talk to me if you
hurt people it's one thing if you steal
it's like uh I know I mean you're
probably that lady looked that late
[Music]
and she got arrested yeah like if you
stole food because your kids were hungry
oh I'm letting you have it 100 but but
if you're stealing yeah
the sad thing that she's seen them was
it makeup it's a small business though
also like still lingerie you don't need
that yeah it's a small business she's
probably she had many times she's done
that you know how many times she's
stolen from people oh I know it's not
the first time there are the the thieves
suck that's why I like turkey cut her
hand off but see if she steals again
it's not turkey but yeah Saudi Arabia
yeah and turkey I don't think so pretty
sure bring it up
remember Singapore I remember if you
like spit or something
crazy like that yeah I know that's what
one channel with drugs you got hung dude
one Championship was asking me to
Compton Singapore I'm like
um
but it's like wait I can't pee outside
Bubba the best food in the world you're
gonna love it I know but if I fart on
the bus am I going to jail probably
chewing gum we're wearing your hair long
like you he was a benevolent dictator
you still there nope he died I think his
son's running the show and you see the
same they cannot do I have to cut my
hair Lee Kuan knew it goes down as one
of the great figures of
certainly
political history in some ways but you
can't have long hair big dick I'm
screwed yeah he was like no I'm screwed
these people chewing gum dude no big
dick man and if there was a homeless guy
in Singapore they were confusion it was
Chinese it was Confucius like the
harmony clean orderly I mean it was
incredible Jake can you look if you have
a big dick in uh Singapore I think I
think because if I'm going to jail for
that lock me up my right big dick you
might be up but but uh yeah
let's just do it for fun average size oh
no is it true that Singapore only have
short penises not totally true written
by a Singaporean dude
the human penis length is about five
inches on average well I'm crushing
everybody dude I'm Godzilla in Singapore
daddy right all right what do you got
Jim
all right uh this is another one Georgie
that's this one here yeah this is a fan
art that the fans made for you it's a
little earthworm braai it's great it's
like Harry something well done Harry
Baldwin 94. earthworm bright why am I
earthworm again oh my neck I told you
your neck looks like an earthworm
that's a good that's a good that's
really good I have more hair than that I
mean that Harry baldness that guy's got
more hair than I do but and a stronger
job but I'm not your hair's coming back
it is at least darker that's what you
look like now yeah it really is coming
back it's [__] amazing what else you
got dude and you could do if you're
super insecure about that stuff you
could do the tattoo yeah
a neck tattoo yeah you can hide it I was
about doing that for my psoriasis coach
going from my neck all the way down you
can do it now how's your psoriasis way
better yeah
um here's a bear that somehow ended up
at a beach in Florida dude I I couldn't
get over that that uh shark attack on
they caught on tape which one did I say
oh Rogan yeah I hated that
you know when his legs go up that's
because the shark pulled him down oh
yeah
but there's a bear that showed up on a
beach
why is he chilling at the beach they're
saying it's a very small it's from a
sand dunes and he probably wanted to
cool off this is in Florida yeah Florida
that's a baby bear right there yeah it's
a baby hey dude get away from the bear
it looks like a dog that's a small bear
yeah yeah anyway I'll kick that thing
around the [__] snout
this 14 year old kid just got a job with
uh I think SpaceX yeah SpaceX he looks
like he got a job crazy smart hell yeah
yeah she had a big brain on Brad
look at him dude but four years old I
mean sorry four year 14 years old which
is insane that's wild
he's a child prodigy yep
genius he didn't find School challenging
enough and he just he passed every test
that they gave him so that's so that's
cool that SpaceX you know there's no age
limits for you know usually the kids who
are that [__] smart they call him on
the Spectrum I just think they're so
smart they can't [__] with our
wavelength I think they're so we're like
no they need to do better no no he's so
much more advanced than where we're at
as a [__] culture you know what I'm
saying like he's so smart people go he
doesn't think the way we do don't talk
yeah because our stuff is so rudimentary
to him you think he's has an issue
that's how smart he is that's right
um here's just a fun one so you guys
know who Kevin Gates is yeah rapper very
inspirational guy so I'll just play this
clip for you okay he likes the butthole
licked I love that does he yeah so he's
a rapper I like him and then Georgie
knows the story he got famous in prison
or something yeah his mixtape came out
he was a down in Louisiana and he blew
up while in prison so when he got out
Newfound Fame yeah new teeth Newfound
Fame so I'll just play this clip for you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I hide the kitties all very funny video
hey kids all
God bless
take you down take you down oh Ryan
Seacrest yeah so I guess he's gonna he's
in the early talks to replace Pat Sajak
how much money do you need Ryan I'd
rather die could we have his money you
want to do a daily [__] game show
dude okay dude whatever you're running
from uh
yeah I've been going two hours all the
money dude that's what happens when we
rock and roll yeah I get another shot
you can't handle it let us know all
right let's roll this all right we're
good man hope you guys enjoyed I'll see
you in uh Denver June uh 29th 30th and
July 1st Blue Room I got Blue Room July
20 21 22. yep and I got uh
I'm in Greensboro North Carolina too
guys I don't remember that but anyway
and July 28 29 I'm at The Improv oh we
got some big news come for me and Brian
Little Theater run here we'll have
announcements for you okay uh next close
one shop and Friends Pasadena July 28th
uh one show only 8 p.m and then I'll be
around I'm at Laugh Factory Saturday be
doing sets all next week in L.A but I'm
in La baby all right guys love you see
ya